, IN NOVEMBER AND DECEMBER, THE
WORLD WATCHED WITH AMAZEMENT AS
UKRAINIAN FORCES LIBERATED ONE
TOWN AND CITY AFTER ANOTHER.
IT SEEMS NOW AS THOUGH THE WAR
HAS MOVED INTO SOMETHING THAT
LOOKS MORE LIKE A STALEMATE.
CAN YOU TELL US WHAT THE WAR
LOOKS LIKE TO YOU ON THE FRONT
LINES RIGHT NOW?
>> >> TRANSLATOR:.
I THINK --
THE WAR DOESN'T LOOK GOOD.
IT HAS NOT BEEN GOOD SINCE THE
BEGINNING AND THE WINTERTIME,
IT FOR NO
UNDERSTANDABLE REASONS.
EVERYONE GETS TIED TO NATURE.
THE PEOPLE, THE ENEMY AS WELL.
HOW LOOKS >> IT LOOKS AS
FOLLOWS.
DAILY, IN THIS FIGHT IN THE
EAST OF THE COUNTRY, WE ARE
STANDING STRONGLY, RESOLUTELY,
AND THANKFUL TO --
THE LIVING ONES AND THE ONES WE
HAVE LOST FOR THEIR BRAVERY.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT WE
ARE STRONG.
IT'S REALLY HARD WHAT WE ARE
ALSO STRONG INSIDE OUR NATION
AND OUR STATE.
WE ARE UNITED BECAUSE WE ARE
MOTIVATED.
IT WAS NOT US WHO STARTED THE
WAR, BUT IT IS US WHO WILL HAVE
TO END IT.
WE WILL HAVE TO END IT ON OUR
LENGTH, HAVING IT OCCUPIED.
WITH RESPECT OUR PEOPLE AND OUR
SOVEREIGNTY, AS WE GET OTHER
PARTS OF OUR --
THE SOUTH, THE NORTH PARTS --
[INAUDIBLE]
IT IS NOT JUST ABOUT US STAYING
UNITED INSIDE THE COUNTRY.
WE NEED TO HAVE THE WORLD
UNITED.
BECAUSE OF THAT, WE TRULY NEED
TO CONTINUE WITH THE SUPPORT OF
UKRAINE, TO CONTINUE WITH
SUPPLIES OF NECESSARY
AMMUNITION THAT WE REQUIRE TO
GET TO THE ELEMENT OF THAT.
WE ALSO NEED THE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
NATIONS FOR THEIR SUPPORT OF
OUR BUDGET DEFICIT AND THE
CONTINUING SUPPORT OF US THIS
YEAR.
I ALSO THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT, GIVEN THE
ENERGY CHALLENGES WE ARE SEEING,
THESE ARE SURELY RELATED TO
DISRESPECTS OF THE HUMANKIND.
YOU KNOW OF THE EFFECTS AGAINST
OUR ENERGY SECTOR, WITH THE
RUSSIAN MISSILES IN ORDER TO --
[INAUDIBLE]
LOTS OF THESE.
I KNOW --
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK MANY
COUNTRIES WORLDWIDE FOR THEIR
ASSISTANCE.
WITH ALTERNATIVE ENERGY
CONNECTIVITY SOLUTIONS FROM
WHAT HE LOOKS LIKE RIGHT NOW,
RUSSIA INTENDS TO GET THIS
REVENGE AND THAT THEY WILL NOT
SUCCEED BECAUSE THEY ARE
FIGHTING NOT JUST UKRAINE BUT
TOWARDS ITS WHOLE LIFE.
THANK YOU.
>> YESTERDAY IN DAVOS, HENRY
KISSINGER SUGGESTED THAT WHILE
UKRAINE MUST BE SUPPORTED, HE
CAME OUT IN FAVOR OF UKRAINE'S
MEMBERSHIP IN NATO.
THERE MUST ALSO BE A DIALOGUE
WITH RUSSIA BECAUSE RUSSIA MUST
BE A PART OF THE GLOBAL ORDER.
YOU KNOW RUSSIA VERY WELL.
YOU SPEAK RUSSIAN FLUENTLY.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
RUSSIA'S PLACE IN THE WORLD?
>> TRANSLATOR: I DON'T KNOW THE
PROPER POLICE.
I THINK THAT RUSSIA HAS ALREADY
EARNED A PLACE AMONG
TERRORISTS.
THIS NO LONGER DEPENDS ON THEIR
LEADERSHIP.
I THINK THEIR LEADERS ARE NO
LONGER AFFECTING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE RUSSIAN
FEDERATION AND SO ON.
EVERYTHING DEPENDS ON THE
STRENGTH OF UKRAINE, ITS
SUPPORT BY THE PARTNERS.
THE POLITICAL SUPPORT FROM THE
WORLD AS WELL AS FROM RUSSIAN
SOCIETY.
THEY HAVE TO OPEN THEIR EYES IF
THEY WANT TO SEE THE FUTURE OF
THE RUSSIAN FEDERATION WITH
THEIR EYES.
THEY WILL HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THEIR OWN MISTAKES.
THEY WILL HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THE
STATUTES.
THEY WILL HAVE TO REALLY
RESPECT OUR TERRITORIAL
INTEGRITY.
I'M REALLY GLAD TO HEAR THAT
MR. KISSINGER CHANGED HIS MIND.
OUR PRIORITY TODAY, OUR
POLITICAL PRIORITY IS TO SEE
THE DIFFERENT POLITICAL LEADERS
AND FIGURES, THOSE WHO ARE
STILL RELEVANT, WHO HAVE BEEN
RELEVANT SPECIFICALLY.
FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE THE GREAT MISTAKE
THAT PUTIN COMMITTED, FOR THEM
TO RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS
RUSSIA'S AGGRESSION, THESE
MOMENTS, IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
FOR THEM AS WELL TO PUT
POLITICAL PRESSURE ON RUSSIA TO
STOP THIS BLOODY AGGRESSION.
WE CLEARLY UNDERSTAND THAT
SECURITY GUARANTEES ARE AMONG
THE TOP PRIORITIES FOR US.
IT IS AMONG THE TOP PRIORITIES.
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT AT THE
MOMENT WE TALK --
[INAUDIBLE]
WE ARE ON THE WAY TOWARDS NATO
BECAUSE NATO IS THE BEST
SECURITY GUARANTEE FOR US, FOR
OUR COUNTRY, FOR OUR WORLD.
WE HAVE SUGGESTED SECURITY
GUARANTEES.
WE THINK THAT THE CIVILIZED
WORLD IS GOING TO SUPPORT OUR
PROPOSALS.
>> FINALLY, MISTER PRESIDENT,
THE ACCIDENT, THE HELICOPTER
CRASH, WE THINK IT WAS AN
ACCIDENT.
WE HOPE IT WAS AN ACCIDENT.
IT DID RAISE IN MY MIND AND
MUST HAVE RAISED IN YOUR MIND
THE QUESTION OF YOUR OWN
SAFETY.
DO YOU FEEL THAT THERE ARE
STILL ONGOING ACTIVE THREATS
THAT ARE INCREASING?
DO YOU WORRY ABOUT YOUR OWN
SECURITY EVERY DAY?
>> TRANSLATOR: NO.
I AM NOT WORRIED ABOUT THAT.
>> I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD
HERE.
>> YOU SAID IT.
YOU DON'T NEED ARRIVING, EAT
AMMUNITION.
>> TRANSLATOR: NOTHING HAS
CHANGED.
WE STILL NEED AMMUNITION.
I'M NOT --
[INAUDIBLE]
YOU SAID ACCIDENT.
I WOULD LIKE TO TELL YOU THAT
BECAUSE OF THE EXPERIENCE THAT
I HAVE NOW, BUT HIS I.T. HAS
NOW, THIS IS NOT AN ACCIDENT
BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN TO --
THIS HAS MANY DIMENSIONS.
LOOK AT THE BATTLEFIELD.
THERE ARE NO ACCIDENTS AT
WARTIME.
THESE ARE ALL WORE RESULTS.
ALTHOUGH EVERYTHING HAD BEEN
HAPPENING, MISSILES STRIKING OR
CIVILIANS, OUR KIDS BEING
KILLED IN KINDERGARTENS AND
SCHOOLS, SOMEONE MIGHT THREATEN
ME, GET THE INFORMATION THAT IT
WAS US WHO HIT OUR OWN
CIVILIANS IN THE CROSSHAIRS AND
THEY WANTED TO HIT A POWER
BLOCK THAT JUST WAS A MISHAP
AND --
JUST EMPTY WORDS.
EVERY INDIVIDUAL, EVERY DEATH
IS A RESULT OF THE WAR.
>> MISTER PRESIDENT, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
YOU'VE BEEN VERY GENEROUS.
BEST OF LUCK.